Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Die 2. Liga kriegt einen auf die Zielgeraden, die ersten Entscheidungen wurden getroffen. Darüber wollen wir sprechen im Rasenfunk Kurzpass mit Oliver Leiste von 120 Minuten und dem EM der A. Oliver, freut mich sehr, dass du hier bist.
Hi. Hi, grüß dich.
Sag uns doch mal kurz den Hörerinnen und Hörern, die dich vielleicht noch nicht kennen, obwohl du schon mal im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst. Wo kann man dich denn überall hören?
Naja, ich bin beim MDR, da bin ich beim Podcast über den 1. FC Magdeburg. Neues vom Krügelplatz heißt ja zu hören. Außerdem machen wir einen Podcast über den Halleschen FC, der Badkurven-Versteher. Und ganz oft bin ich auch im 120-Minuten-Podcast zu hören.
Genau, also schon ein Podcast-Urgestein fast schon. Und du lenkst damit auch schon den Blick auf den Schwerpunkt, den wir in dieser Sendung haben werden. Wir werden unter anderem über den 1. FC Magdeburg sprechen, über sprechen dürfen, den ich in der allerersten Kurzpassaufgabe als 1. FC Magdeburg angesprochen habe. Dann wurde ich sofort korrigiert, habe in der zweiten, im zweiten Rasenfunk-Kurzpass zur zweiten Liga dann schon auf Magdeburg umgeschwenkt. Aber ich habe jetzt eine Tasse bekommen, einfach anonym zugesandt. Herzlichen Dank dafür, lieber anonymer Zusender oder Zusenderin. Da stand drauf, es heißt Magdeburg. Also wie, was soll ich denn jetzt sagen?
Ich denke, Magdeburg ist schon okay. Das ist im normalen Sprachgebrauch so etabliert. Wenn du jetzt tatsächlich in Magdeburg unterwegs sein solltest, müsstest du Magdeburg sagen.
Magdeburg, okay. Also auf der Tasse steht nämlich, es heißt Magdeburg. Aber dann bleibe ich bei Magdeburg. Ich will mich ja auch nicht anbiedern. Aber vielleicht werde ich jetzt einfach auch ein paar andere Namen hier falsch aussprechen, weil es natürlich eine willkommene Überraschung ist, eine wirklich sehr hübsche Tasse auf einmal in der Post zu haben, ohne weiteren Kommentar. Vielleicht sollten wir dann mal auf die Spiele gucken, dieses 32. Spieltags und ich habe schon gesagt, es gab die allerersten Entscheidungen in dieser Liga und da müssen wir uns unbedingt dem 1. FC Kühlen widmen, denn der ist jetzt aufgestiegen in die erste Liga mit einem 4 zu 0 bei Greuther Fürth. Wie würdest du aus deiner Sicht, die ja so ein bisschen sich auf Magdeburg konzentriert und jetzt ja auch dann in der 2. Liga jetzt in dieser Saison so einen besonderen Saisonverlauf hat, wie hast du das alles wahrgenommen, was da beim FC passiert ist?
Ja, also wenn man vor der Saison darüber gesprochen hat, war natürlich klar, der HSV und der 1. FC Kühlen steigen auf. Das sah ja dann auch lange so aus, als ob das genau so passieren wird. Und es war nur eine Frage, wer wird jetzt 1. wer wird 2.? Bekanntermaßen hat der HSV jetzt ganz schön abreißen lassen. So der FC, die hatten ja jetzt schon zwei oder drei Matchbälle, die sie irgendwie vergeigt haben. Jetzt haben sie es endlich geschafft. Also im Ende war es im Vorfeld eine Frage der Zeit. Und auch wenn man sich einfach die Qualität der Mannschaft anguckt und insbesondere der Offensive, dann war klar, dass da irgendwie nichts schiefgehen konnte. Und ja, ich war mit in Köln, als der FCM dort gespielt hat und hatte danach auch eine Folge FCM Podcast mit, wo wir in der Kneipe saßen und ein paar nette Kölner einfach mit dazugenommen haben. Und für die freue ich mich jetzt einfach auch, dass die wieder da sind, wo sie eigentlich hingehören, glaube ich.
Genau. Drei Treffer, John Kordoba in diesem Spiel bei Fürth, achte Minute, dann zwanzigste Minute, ein Eigentor, 41. Dann stand es zu halbzeit schon 3 zu 0 und alles sah nach dem Aufstieg auf. 80 Tore hat der FC erzielt, damit die beste Sturmreihe der zweiten Liga allerdings auch 41 kassiert. Es war immer viel los bei Spielen mit dem FC. So weit kann man es, glaube ich, festhalten. Und über das ganze Trainerwechsel-Bohai haben wir ja gesprochen. Ich glaube, so mancher wird sich ein bisschen in den Kopf gekratzt haben, als sie gesagt haben, es war ja für uns alle klar, der FC und der HSV steigen auf. Aber das spiegelt ja auch ganz gut wieder, welche Dynamik diese Saison hatte. Jetzt ist der FC auch deswegen interessant, auch wenn wir über den ersten FC Magdeburg sprechen wollen, weil es am letzten Spieltag zum Aufeinandertreffen kommen wird in Magdeburg. Der FC dann eben schon als sichere Erstliga-Aussteiger, eventuell dann auch Zweitliga-Meister – nein, das ist sogar schon sicher, sehe ich gerade.
Auch das ist schon sicher, genau.
Glaubst du denn, dass das eine Auswirkung haben wird auf dieses letzte Spiel? Ist das jetzt gut für Magdeburg?
Ja, das ist so ein Punkt, der auch schon die ganze Saison überlegt wird, wo sich in Magdeburg eigentlich auch alle einig waren. Naja, die Kölner, die kommen dann schon als sicherer Aufsteiger und vielleicht sind die dann so ein bisschen bierselig und nehmen es nicht mehr ganz so ernst. Ja, das ist jetzt nach wie vor die große Hoffnung. Wenn sie jetzt sogar schon als Meister feststehen, dann spielen sie ja nur noch ums Gewinnen. So und das kann dem FCM helfen, zumal die gegen die besseren Mannschaften der Liga in dieser Saison auch meistens nicht so schlecht ausgesehen haben und sich eher gegen die direkten Konkurrenten sehr schlecht angestellt haben. Das kann dem FCM helfen, aber andererseits hat Köln auch eine brutale Qualität und die haben zwei Stürmer, die beide über 20 Tore geschossen haben in der Saison. Die haben dann noch modest dazu. Die FCM-Abwehr ist immer mal dafür gut, einen durchrutschen zu lassen. Wenn die Kölner jetzt tatsächlich mit Badelatschen, wie man so schön sagt, ankommen und mit zwölf Kölsch drin, dann könnte das dem FCM helfen. Aber andererseits ist der FC so gut, dass er auch trotzdem noch in Magdeburg gewinnen kann.
Und dafür ist es vielleicht dann auch noch zu weit hin, dieses Spiel, dass man da immer noch mit Badelatschen und Kölsch ankommt. Naja, wir werden es beobachten. Über Magdeburg sprechen wir gleich noch ausführlicher. Lass aber erst mal auf das gucken, was hinter dem FC passiert ist. Da weiß man eigentlich gar nicht, wo man anfangen soll. Also von den Plätzen 2 bis zu den Plätzen 8 bis zu Jan Regensburg haben alle Mannschaften alle Mannschaften verloren. Paderborn, Union, HSV, Heidenheim, St. Pauli, Heustern, Kiel und Jan Regensburg. Alle verloren. Und besonders dramatisch ist das natürlich für die erst genannten drei Vereine. Paderborn, Berlin und den HSV. Lass mal bei Paderborn beginnen. Das war ein 0 zu 2 in Bielefeld am Freitagabend. Wie beurteilst du das aus deiner Erfahrung, jetzt die du in dieser zweiten Liga gesammelt hast? Ist das etwas, was Paderborn mit sich rumtragen wird? Kommt das daher, dass sie jetzt auf einmal etwas zu verlieren haben, dass da der Kopf einsetzt? Was ist deine Ferndiagnose?
Ja, wenn wir auf die Tabelle schauen, ist ja die zweite Liga insgesamt extrem ausgeglichen. Bielefeld, die standen jetzt auch relativ lange weit unten, haben weit unter ihren Möglichkeiten gespielt. Die sind letztes Jahr, glaube ich, Vierter oder Fünfter geworden. Da haben alle erwartet, dass sie diesmal so einen Platz drei mitspielen. Dann hatten sie relativ große Probleme, da haben sie sich jetzt raus befreit. Aber insgesamt ist Bielefeld eine gute Zweitligamannschaft, glaube ich. Ja, Paderborn, darf ich nicht vergessen, die sind ein Aufsteiger. Die hatten phasenweise eine relativ wackelige Defensive. Da war ähnlich wie beim FC Köln immer Spektakel angesagt. Ich glaube, das wird jetzt sich umwerfen. Das kann auch schon mal passieren, dass man ein Spiel verliert. Vor der Saison hätte jetzt wahrscheinlich keiner erwartet, dass der SC Paderborn tatsächlich ernsthaft wieder um den Aufstieg in die Bundesliga spielt. Ich habe aber ein bisschen die Befürchtung, dass sie es am Ende tatsächlich schaffen werden.
Warum Befürchtung?
Ach ja, das ist ja einfach so eine krasse Geschichte bei denen. Die sind in die Bundesliga aufgestiegen, sind dann im Prinzip durchgereicht worden bis in die vierte Liga, sind nur in der dritten Liga dringeblieben, weil 60 keine Lizenz bekommen hat für die zweite Bundesliga.
Hassan Ismaik ist wahrscheinlich nur in Paderborn beliebt.
Genau. Ich glaube, die bauen ihm da auch ein Denkmal vor das Stadion. Und dann sind sie, nachdem sie am grünen Tisch in der dritten Liga dringeblieben sind, im nächsten Jahr aufgestiegen und steigen jetzt vielleicht schon wieder auf. Also dieses Hin und Her ist nicht nachvollziehbar und deswegen befürchte ich so ein bisschen, dass die weiter ihrer Leidenschaft fröhen, keine Saison in der gleichen Liga zu spielen.
Ja gut, das ist halt die Fahrstuhlmannschaft auf Speed, würde man fast schon sagen. Also das ist ja fast schon Pater Noster, der geht dann unten einfach einmal ums Eck und kommt dann wieder in die andere Richtung raus. Paderbahn hat es auf jeden Fall in der eigenen Hand jetzt mit dem Heimspiel gegen den HSV aktuell bei 54 Punkten. Man hat einen Punkt Vorsprung auf Union Berlin und einen Punkt Vorsprung auf den HSV. Mit einem Sieg jetzt zu Hause könnte man das schon mal sicher machen, dass man vom HSV nicht mehr eingeholt wird und dann hängt es von Union Berlin ab, was da passiert. Also eine extrem interessante Konstellation und in der nächsten Woche werden wir vermutlich auch da noch mal genauer draufblicken, hier im Zweitliga-Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Dann lass uns mal weiterblicken auf Union Berlin, die auf Platz 3 liegen. Die hatten die große Chance als einzige Mannschaft, die schon wusste, dass der HSV verlieren wurde und dass der SC Paderborn verloren hatte, nachzuziehen in Darmstadt am Sonntagnachmittag. Und was soll man sagen? Auch das hat nicht funktioniert. Ein 2 zu 1, bei dem Union erst in der Schlussphase so ein bisschen wie ein Aufsteiger auch gespielt hat. Vorher war es eher durchschnittlich, würde ich das jetzt so beschreiben. Was glaubst du, was fehlt denn da bei Union, dass man diese wichtigen Schritte immer und immer wieder nicht geht?
Ja, das ist jetzt aus der Ferne, die jetzt hier von Leipzig oder von Magdeburg aus gar nicht so groß ist, schwer einzuschätzen. Fakt ist seit Jahren ist Union irgendwie ein Aufstiegskandidat. Die werden immer wieder mitgehandelt. Die haben sich irgendwo auch dazu bekannt, dass sie den Schritt in die Bundesliga mal gehen wollen. So bauen ihr Stadion entsprechend auf und so weiter. Tja, bei denen ist es, glaube ich, eher als bei Paderborn. Die haben tatsächlich Angst davor. Also immer, wenn die merken, oh jetzt könnte es ernst werden, verlieren sie irgendwie ein Spiel und rutschen dadurch auf Platz 3 oder auf Platz 4, sodass es dann am Ende irgendwie nicht in die Notsituation kommt, sich ernsthaft mit dem Aufstieg beschäftigen zu müssen. So mein Gefühl. Und ja, zeigen das auch schon die ganze Saison, dass sie es eben nie geschafft haben. Also Köln und der HSV, die hatten sich ja zwischendurch auch mal abgesetzt. Union ist immer irgendwie mit drangeblieben, ist aber nie vorbeigekommen. Und halten jetzt im Prinzip so die ganze Saison mehr oder weniger diesen dritten Platz. Ich glaube, sie waren mal ein oder zwei Spieltage zweiter, waren mal vierter, aber sind eigentlich immer dritter. Und ja, woran es jetzt liegt, kann ich dir nicht genau sagen. Aber wie gesagt, da ist so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass sie tatsächlich aus irgendwelchen Gründen Angst davor haben.
Es ist auf jeden Fall schon eine interessante Konstellation mit 14 Unentschieden und nur fünf Niederlagen mit weitem Abstand die wenigsten in dieser zweiten Liga. Und dennoch könnte noch alles passieren, vom direkten Aufstieg bis hin zum Verpassen der Relegation. Und Jon ist auch deswegen vielleicht ein bisschen mehr jetzt in deinem Fokus in dieser Woche, weil die jetzt eben ihr Heimspiel gegen Magdeburg haben, bevor sie dann auswärts beim VfL Bochum ran müssen. Was erwartest du dir für die Partie? Du hast vorhin gesagt, Magdeburg tut sich eher leicht gegen Gegner aus dem oberen Tabellendrittel. Oder leichter?
Wenn man jetzt ganz ehrlich ist, hat der FCM nichts mehr zu verlieren. Die sind jetzt Vorletzter. Ingolstadt, da werden wir ja noch sprechen. Die haben den Lauf. Da kann man jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarten, dass man die noch abfängt. Das heißt, der FCM spielt irgendwie um die Chance, vielleicht noch dran zu bleiben. Das ist so mein Gefühl. Union, wie auch schon in den Vorwochen, spielt darum, womöglich aufzusteigen. Aber ich glaube, da ist die Erwartungshaltung bei den Unionern deutlich größer. Das ist so ein bisschen die Chance für den FCM. Ich traue dem FCM schon zu, dass er auch bei Union punktet.
Wie häufig, würdest du sagen, gab es das in dieser Saison schon, dass Magdeburg wirklich befreit aufgespielt hat? Ich habe einige Partien von ihm gesehen. Gerade am Beginn der Saison hat man genauer hingeguckt, wie machen sich eigentlich die Aufsteiger und gerade Magdeburg mit dem Heimpublikum im Rücken. Ich hatte den Eindruck, dass Magdeburg schon zu den Mannschaften gehört hat, die vor allem in der Sekunde, in der sie dann in Rückstand geraten, sehr verkrampft wirken und manchmal nicht so klar ihrem Plan folgen, den sie vielleicht bis zum Rückstand hatten. Das dann häufig in vielen Partien, die ich dann gesehen hatte, wurde es dann eher schlimmer als besser. Hat sich das jetzt gedreht ein bisschen in dieser Saison oder würdest du da vielleicht mehr sogar widersprechen?
Also gedreht hat sich das, glaube ich, nicht. Das war auch in der Rückrunde in vielen Spielen so, wenn sie dann in Rückstand geraten sind, dass sie dann mitunter eingeknickt haben oder nicht mehr so richtig wussten, wie sie darauf jetzt reagieren sollen. Oder manchmal haben sie dann auch offen weitergespielt, aber dann einfach auch hinten zu viele Fehler gemacht, so wie jetzt zuletzt gegen Bochum. Große, große Ausnahme war sicherlich das Spiel beim HSV, als der HSV auch führte und als der FCM das Spiel gedreht hat und dann eben in der Nachspielzeit in der 93. Minute gewonnen hat. Zur großen Überraschung von allen damals Anwesenden.
Das war eins von zwei Spielen, wo man nach Rückstand noch drei Punkte geholt hat.
Das andere war gegen Fürth vor zwei Wochen. Ja, so und ich meine da Greuther Fürth, die sind momentan auch nicht gut drauf. Die verlieren ja auch jedes Spiel und die haben da einfach wahnsinnige Geschenke verteilt in Magdeburg. Also die haben schon zwei Fehlpässe aus der letzten Reihe gespielt, bevor es 1-0 für Fürth stand und haben dann einfach weitergemacht und haben da wirklich unfassbare Sachen gemacht und die hat der FCM dann mal angenommen. Also eigentlich hätte es da zur Halbzeit schon 4-1 für den FCM stehen müssen, nur nach Geschenken von Fürth. So stand es dann 2-1 und das haben sie dann auch über die Zeit gebracht. Das war in der Summe verdient, aber daraus konnte man jetzt keine Trendwende erkennen. Das war irgendwie so eine Ausnahme und wie gesagt die große Ausnahme war eben das Spiel beim HSV.
Gut, also das ist die zweite interessante Partie jetzt des nächsten, des 33. Spieltags. Nicht nur der HSV wird da in Paderborn antreten, sondern Union eben zu Hause gegen Magdeburg und dann wird sich da in dieser Dreierkonstellation etwas getan haben, denn alle verlieren können sie wieder nicht. Das ist jetzt wenigstens mal sicher. Womit wir dann eben auch mal auf den HSV gucken könnten. Das ist die dritte Mannschaft. Rein rechnerisch kann man Heidenheim noch mit rein rechnen ums Rennen um Platz 3, aber der HSV mit einem Punkt Rückstand auf Platz 2 ist natürlich noch am engsten in der Verlosung. Hannes Wolf durfte bleiben trotz eines 0 zu 3 zu Hause gegen Ingolstadt. Jetzt wirst du da vielleicht so ein bisschen ein Déjà-vu haben, denn wir haben ja schon drüber gesprochen. Magdeburg hat auch in Hamburg gewonnen. Ich hatte das Gefühl, also mal unabhängig davon, dass Ingolstadt gerade einen Lauf hat, über die müssen wir gleich noch ausführlicher sprechen, war ab dem 0 zu 1 zu spüren, das ist wieder eines dieser Heimspiele, was der HSV gegen einen Gegner aus den unteren Tabellenregionen in keinem Fall gewinnen wird. Was passiert denn da immer in diesen Heimspielen in Hamburg, dass die verloren gehen, obwohl sie nicht verloren gehen müssten, wenn man jetzt nur mal aus Sportliche guckt?
Ja, das ist jetzt auch wieder schwer zu erklären. Ich wollte gerade mal noch nachgucken. Der HSV hat ja jetzt auch schon ewig nicht zuhause gewonnen. Also das ist dann natürlich so ein Komplex. Und gegen den FC M, da waren sie dann zwischenzeitlich auch besser. Da waren jetzt nicht so super viele Chancen dabei, aber sie haben das Spiel irgendwo dominiert. Danach kam, glaube ich, ein 1-1 gegen Auer. Aber auch davor waren ja schon ein paar Spiele, die der HSV zuhause nicht gewonnen hat. Und jetzt gegen Ingolstadt war es tatsächlich wahrscheinlich so. Dann kam irgendwie das 1-0 für Ingolstadt. Und dann werden die gedacht haben, oh, jetzt geht das schon wieder los. Und dann gehen natürlich die Köpfe und die Schultern so ein bisschen runter. Und dann lässt du dich da so abschießen. Und dann Ingolstadt, die haben natürlich jetzt gerade einen Lauf, haben seitdem der neue Trainer, da ist, glaube ich, noch kein Spiel verloren und auch nur einen Unentschieden geholt in vier oder fünf Spielen. So. Und die sagen dann natürlich, so, jetzt heute sind wir da, und dann holen wir das.
Also der letzte Heimsieg war am 24. Spieltag zuhause gegen Gräute-Fürth, ein 1 zu 0. Irgendwie mit leichten Referenzen an eine Relegation, die es da mal gab. Und seitdem, und das ist Anfang März, am 4. März war dieses Spiel seitdem zuhause entweder Unentschieden oder tatsächlich verloren, was häufiger vorkam.
Genau. Und auch nur, ich sehe es gerade, auch nur gegen potenzielle Abstiegskandidaten gegen Darmstadt, die damals noch unten drinhingen, gegen Magdeburg, gegen Auer, gegen Ingolstadt. Ja.
Und nur gegen Auer gab es ein Unentschieden. Also sehr interessante Konstellation beim HSV, sehr interessant, auch wie man darauf jetzt reagiert, indem man nicht den üblichen Reflex nachgibt und jetzt Hannes Wolf ersetzt durch einen anderen Trainer, sondern das irgendwie versucht, durchzustehen. Die Alarmglocken sind an, jetzt geht es nach Paderborn. Immerhin an Paderborn hat der HSV in dieser Saison gute Erinnerungen. Man hat schon zweimal gegen Paderborn gespielt und zwar einmal im DFB-Pokal gewonnen und dann zu Hause. Das müsste auch gewonnen worden sein, wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf habe. Genau, das war ein 1 zu 0 am 16. Spieltag. Das ist vielleicht das Positivste, was der HSV gerade mitnehmen kann. Jetzt könnte man noch sprechen über Heidenheim, die gegen Sandhausen 2 zu 3 verloren haben, aber rein rechnerisch mit 4 Punkten Rückstand auf den dritten Platz noch mit drin sind. Über St. Pauli, die in Dresden ein emotionales Spiel mit 1 zu 2 verloren haben. St. Pauli war ja auch ein bisschen Schwerpunkt des letzten Kurzpasses. Kiel hat gegen Duisburg verloren. Ich finde aber, wir sind jetzt in dieser Saisonphase, wo man sich wirklich darauf konzentrieren kann, was passiert oben, was passiert unten. Deswegen lass mal dann jetzt nach unten springen und dann vielleicht auch ganz hinten anfangen mit Duisburg, wenn ich das jetzt gerade schon so erwähne. In Kiel 2 zu 0 gewonnen und plötzlich rein rechnerisch mit 4 Punkten Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz. Eventuell doch ein bisschen noch am Leben der MSV. Welchen Puls würdest du ihnen diagnostizieren?
Also ganz ehrlich, für mich ist der MSV Duisburg abgestiegen. Auch wenn sie jetzt gegen Kiel gewonnen haben oder noch mal so einen kleinen Hoffnungsschimmer haben. Aber 4 Punkte, zwei Spieltage vor Schluss ist auch schon relativ viel. Das bedeutet, Duisburg muss beide gewinnen, Ingolstadt muss beide verlieren oder kann noch einen Unentschieden holen. Ingolstadt hat auch das deutlich bessere Torverhältnis. Also da glaube ich persönlich nicht mehr dran, dass ich der MSV Duisburg retten kann. Und da gibt es ja auch den Zebra-Streifen-Block, den ich auch immer so ein bisschen im Auge habe. Kees Jaratz, wunderbarer Mensch, der da immer sehr intensiv mitleidet. Oder er hat immer seinen Tabellenrechner, wo er sich und anderen MSV-Fans vorrechnet, warum es doch noch klappen kann, mit was auch immer sie erreichen wollen in der jeweiligen Saison. Und wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe, hat er den letzte Woche eingestellt. Und das sagt so ungefähr alles über die Hoffnung, die noch für den MSV Duisburg aus meiner Sicht bestehen.
Also es geht jetzt dann noch zu Hause gegen Heidenheim, für die es rein rechnerisch noch möglich ist aufzusteigen. Und dann auswärts zum HSV. Also das ist jetzt auch nicht das einfachste aller Restprogramme für den MSV.
Ich meine, beim HSV ist natürlich ein sicherer Sieg für die Burg. Aber gegen Heidenheim, die sind schon so gut, dass die jetzt nicht unbedingt gegen Duisburg verlieren, glaube ich.
Woran wird es dann gelegen haben, wenn es für den MSV runtergeht in die dritte Liga? Was ist da deine Diagnose?
Na ja, seitdem die damals auch den Lizenzentzug hatten und das erste Mal runter in die dritte Liga mussten, kommen die auch nicht mehr so richtig auf die Beine. Also sie schaffen es dann irgendwie doch immer noch in der dritten Liga relativ schnell wieder aufzusteigen. Beim ersten Mal haben sie zwei Jahre gebraucht, beim zweiten Mal haben sie es direkt repariert und halten sich dann im ersten Jahr immer irgendwie in der zweiten Liga und rutschen dann wieder ab. Also irgendwie, keine Ahnung, durch den Lizenzentzug ist ihnen die zweite Liga so ein bisschen zu groß geworden. Das ist so mein Gefühl.
Und das ist dann zurückzuführen auf einfach wirtschaftliche Mittel, die fehlen, um entsprechend dann durch Geldeinsatz eine Qualität im Kader herzustellen? Oder wie würdest du das beschreiben?
Danach sieht es ganz klar aus, ja. Weil du ja wirklich dann auch immer versuchst, mit dem Drittligakader erstmal zurechtzukommen. Dann hast du so eine gewisse Aufstiegseuphorie, die dich so ein bisschen trägt. Aber dadurch, dass es jetzt eben schon zum zweiten Mal so passiert, dass sie dann wieder runtergehen müssen, würde ich es darauf schieben, ja.
Also es ist schon wirklich interessant, wenn man sich mal die Transferbilanz vom MSV anguckt in den letzten Jahren. Zu dieser Saison hin nur ablösefreie Spieler verpflichtet und mit dem Verkauf von Marc Flecken und Richard Tsukuta-Paso hat man immerhin 1, 3 Millionen Euro eingenommen. In der Saison davor nur ablösefreie Spieler geholt und dafür 50.000 Euro für ein Spieler bekommen. In der Saison davor nur ablösefreie Spieler geholt und so weiter und so fort. Also wenn man die ganzen letzten Jahre zurückgeht, da sieht man mal, da wurden mal 50.000 für einen Spieler aus der zweiten von Wolfsburg auf den Tisch gelegt. Aber ansonsten ausnahmslos ablösefreie Spieler oder vielleicht mal eine Laie. Man muss bis ins Jahr 2011 zurückgehen, also zur Saison 2011, 2012, um mal Zugänge zu sehen, die im Bereich von 450.000 Euro, 200.000 Euro, 100.000 Euro, alle Daten jetzt von Transfermarkt.de liegen. Und selbst da wurde das aufgewogen mit Abgaben. Selbst in dieser Saison hatte man ein Transferminus von 100.000 Euro. Also das zeigt das ja, was du beschrieben hast, ganz deutlich. Der MSV muss jetzt schon seit Jahren improvisieren, wenn es um Transfers geht und muss da die kostengünstigste Variante wählen. Und damit ist es halt schwierig, dann eine Liga zu halten.
Genau. Ich meine, damals, 2011, da haben sie noch um den Aufstieg in die Bundesliga gespielt, oder? Wenn ich das so richtig, oder waren sie zumindest im erweiterten Kreis der KG-Daten. So und genau. Ich meine, prinzipiell muss das nichts Schlechtes sein, sich mit ablöserfreien Spielern zu verstärken. Also in der dritten Liga funktioniert das ja fast ausschließlich so. Aber ja, klar, ab und zu kannst du dir auch mal helfen, wenn du sagst, ok, du kannst eben mal 200.000, 300.000 für einen Spieler auf den Tisch legen, der dir dann auch hilft.
Ja, und vor allem bringt das dich halt einfach in diesen Druck, im Scouting immer wieder nachzulegen, weil denen den ablösefreien Zugang stehen ja dann auch Verkäufe entgegen. Jetzt nicht in riesiger Millionenhöhe, aber du musst immer wieder Spieler ersetzen. Und ich glaube, als Verein, die Ablösesummen sind ja quasi nur der kleinere Teil des Kostenfaktors. Der größere sind ja die Personalkosten. Und wenn jemand bei Ablösen so sparsam ist – gut, da könnten wir jetzt auch Schlussfolger – das ist eine wahnsinnig hohe Gehälterzeit. Wir wissen aber, so wird es nicht beim MSV sein. Und da darf man sich halt keine Illusionen machen. Das ist für Spieler neben der Frage, wer ist Trainer und welche sportliche Perspektive habe ich, ist das natürlich auch ein Argument, ob ich zu einem MSV Duisburg wechsle oder eben zum Beispiel zu einem FC Ingolstadt oder einem SV Sandhausen oder sogar Sonnenhof Groß-Astbach, die vielleicht dann in manchen Bereichen dann da sogar mehr Mittel zur Verfügung haben als eben der MSV. Ich glaube, das ist dann noch die zweite Komponente, die da mit dazu kommt. Für uns aber halt ein bisschen schwerer sichtbar.
Genau. Wobei ich das jetzt bei Groß-Astbach, da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher. Also, die zahlen schon ganz solide, aber jetzt auch nicht keine Mondpreise für die dritte Liga.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich habe Groß-Astbach gesagt und habe WN Wiesbaden gemeint. Hast du gut aufgedeckt. Gut reagiert, Oliver. Aber dafür bist du halt beim MDR.
Genau, 2. Liga, 3. Liga habe ich alles im Blick.
Da hast du alles im Blick. Dann lass jetzt mal über Magdeburg ausführlicher sprechen. Beschreib mir mal, tun wir einfach mal so, als hätte ich jetzt gar nichts mitbekommen. Ich gucke jetzt einfach nur auf die Tabelle, sehe 17. Tabellenplatz an diesem Spieltag, also am vergangenen Spieltag, am 32. Spieltag abgerutscht auf den 17. Was ist denn die Geschichte dieser Saison dahinter? Wie ist Magdeburg da unten gelandet? Wie ist die Saison verlaufen?
Na ja, du hattest über die letzten Jahre eine sehr große und stetig gewachsene Euphorie, eben bedingt durch den Aufstieg aus dem Amateurfußball bis hin in die 2. Bundesliga. Und eine wahnsinnige Stimmung im Stadion. Und hast eigentlich, oder haben wir in Magdeburg gedacht, dass das auch ein wichtiger Faktor zum Klassenerhalt wird. Diese Stimmung im Magdeburger Stadion, wo in der Drittliga alle gesagt haben, das ist so besonders und wo wirklich Gegner richtig Schiss hatten, wenn die in Magdeburg spielen mussten. Und das ist in der 2. Liga überhaupt nicht zum Tragen gekommen. Der FC M hat jetzt in dieser Saison zwei Heimspiele gewonnen gegen Aue und gegen Fürth jetzt vor zwei Wochen. Und wo man eben merkt, okay, diese Kulisse, 2. Liga-Profis schockt die nicht. Wenn die in Köln, wenn die in Dresden, wenn die in Hamburg spielen müssen, dann halten die auch 20.000 FC M-Fans aus. Und das war sicherlich so der Faktor, was am überraschendsten kam. Also, dass die Heimstärke, die wir eigentlich erwartet hatten, überhaupt nicht zum Tragen kam. Eher im Gegenteil. So. Und dann hattest du am Saisonanfang ein paar ordentliche Spiele dabei. Hattest relativ viel Pech. Oft ist es ja so bei Aufsteigern, dass sie dann am Anfang erstmal relativ viel gewinnen, sich so ein kleines Polster holen, dann in so ein Loch fallen und dann aber, weil sie dieses Polster am Anfang hatten, irgendwie noch in Schlagweite bleiben, dass sie es zum Ende schaffen können. Das ist beim FCM nicht passiert. Die haben sehr viele Unentschieden geholt und sind dadurch aber von vorne rein in diesem, naja, im hinteren Tabellenfeld geblieben. Sind da nie so richtig rausgekommen.
Also aus den ersten sieben Spielen fünf Unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen.
Genau und ich kann mich auch zwischendurch noch mal erinnern, war irgendwann dann so bis Mitte Oktober oder so was eine Phase auch noch mal, wo der FCM sechs Spiele hintereinander nicht verloren hat. Aber auch nur eins gewonnen. Und ja genau, dann kam dann irgendwann eine Zeit, wo sie sehr oft verloren haben, auch immer durch so sehr dumme individuelle Fehler. Dann haben sie Mitte November den Trainer getauscht, den langjährigen Trainer Jens Hertel entlassen, Michael Oening dafür geholt. Und zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo man das sportlich schon sehr gut begründen konnte, diesen Tausch, wo wir gesagt haben, naja, so richtig gut war das nicht, weil die nächsten Gegner waren dann eben Fürth, Bochum, Union und Köln. Also wo man wusste, okay, aus den ersten fünf Spielen war es dann, glaube ich, noch bis Weihnachten, werden sie nichts holen. Und sie haben dann tatsächlich ein oder zwei Punkte geholt.
Ja, unentschieden gegen Union und gegen Bochum an der Stelle. Aber kann man ja auch so argumentieren, dass das Michael Oening dann ein bisschen Zeit gegeben hat. Dadurch, dass die Erwartungshaltung so gering war an die nächsten Wochen, konnte er ja auch in Ruhe starten und hatte nicht diesen Malus, dass er den Trainer-Effekt dadurch beweisen muss, dass jetzt sofort Punkte geholt werden.
Das stört, aber trotzdem erhoffst du dir natürlich, wenn du tauscht, dass das sich dann auch direkt irgendwo tabellarisch niederschlägt. Das ist erstmal nicht passiert, aber das war zu erwarten. Dann sind sie sehr gut aus der Winterpause gekommen, haben gegen Auer gewonnen, haben gegen Ingolstadt gewonnen, waren auch in den Wochen danach gut. Und da haben wir eigentlich alle gedacht, okay, jetzt haben sie es im Griff und jetzt werden sie zumindest mal den Anschluss ans Mittelfeld irgendwie herstellen. Also wo dann eben Auer noch in Sichtweite war, Dynamo Dresden, Darmstadt, wo man so dachte, okay, der FCM punktet jetzt so, dass er an die zumindest mit rankommt und die vielleicht in den Abstiegskampf noch mit reinziehen kann. Das ist nie passiert, weil dann irgendwie die Spiele gegen Duisburg damals letzter und gegen Sandhausen damals letzter beide verloren gingen. Und das war so ein bisschen der Knackpunkt, glaube ich. Und seitdem sind immer mal so ein Hoffnungsschimmer dabei, eben wie das Spiel gegen den HSV. Und dann verlierst du in der Woche danach zu Hause gegen Darmstadt. Und das war jetzt so, dass das wechselbart in den letzten Wochen. Ja, und jetzt stehst du eben da, wo du stehst, hast die schlechteste Offensive der Liga. Die Abwehr ist eigentlich okay. Also klar rutscht da schon irgendwie auch in jedem Spiel mal einer durch, aber die ist eigentlich stabil. Problem ist eben echt die Offensive.
34 Tore nach 32 Spielen sind es jetzt.
Genau, und daran wird es dann wahrscheinlich am Ende der Saison auch scheitern.
Ja, bevor wir dann so ein bisschen darüber sprechen wollen, wie es jetzt dann jetzt aktuell aussieht, würde ich gerne noch mal kurz zurückgehen zum Trainertausch. Jens Härtel hast du erwähnt, der hat die Mannschaft in der Saison 2014-2015 übernommen und von der Regionalliga über die dritte Liga mit guten Ergebnissen auch von Anfang an als Regionalliga-Aufsteiger in der dritten Liga vierter geworden, in der darauffolgenden Saison die Platzierung bestätigt, also zweimal knapp gescheitert und dann als Drittligameister in der Saison 17, 18 aufgestiegen und dann wird er in der zweiten Liga noch in der Hinrunde entlassen. Du hast gesagt, das war sportlich vertretbar. Was glaubst du denn, hat man sich erhofft vom Trainerwechsel? Also ging es da jetzt nur darum, jemanden zu holen, der vielleicht irgendwie Punkte aus diesem Team rausholt, das ja definitiv an sein Leistungsmaximum kommen muss, um die Klasse zu halten? Oder ging es da vielleicht auch ein bisschen darum, dass Michael Öning ein Trainer ist, der einen anderen Erfahrungshorizont mitbringt, als Jens Hertl?
Das war ganz klar ein Faktor. Da waren wir uns auch relativ einig, dass es mit Michael Öning darum ging, auch zu lernen, wie man im Profifußball besteht, weil er nicht nur Jens Hertl bis dato eben mit dem FCM, die dritte Liga, das war das Maximum, was er bis dato trainiert hatte. Davor war er beim Berliner AK, war Nachwuchstrainer bei RB Leipzig und so weiter. Er hatte die Erfahrung nicht, aber auch das Management. Klar, Mike Franz hat Bundesliga und eventuell sogar europäisch mal gespielt, aber er hatte diese höchsten Erfahrungen als Spieler, ist aber als Sportdirektor jetzt auch ganz neu. Den haben sie in der ersten Drittligasaison geholt, damals noch so als Praktikanten. Dann ist er so Schritt für Schritt zum sportlichen Leiter irgendwie aufgestiegen und dann hast du Mario Kalnick, der in seiner Karriere – da bin ich jetzt nicht ganz sicher, weil ich glaube ich auch nie ganz hochklassig gespielt hat, aber der dem FCM über viele Jahre schon als Spieler verbunden war und der als Manager da den Verein entschuldet hat und nach oben gebracht hat, aber der natürlich auch dann eben auf dieser höheren Ebene 2. Bundesliga oder gar Bundesliga keine Erfahrung hat.
Ja, also ging es tatsächlich um diese Erfahrung. Ja, irgendwie auf der einen Seite sehr verständlich, auf der anderen Seite finde ich es ein bisschen bitter aus Sicht desjenigen Trainers, der es eben geschafft hat, diesen zweimaligen Ausstieg von der Regionalliga bis in die 2. Bundesliga und dann bekommst du nicht mal die Chance, dann nochmal in der Winterpause da zu korrigieren, gegenzusteuern, einfach zu gucken, was geht. Denn jetzt Heimstärke hin oder her, die man vor der Saison antizipiert hat, dass es eng werden würde für Magdeburg, das konnte man ja erahnen, oder?
Das war klar, also da sind auch alle von ausgegangen. Aber ich sag mal, die Gründe, die Mario Kalnick damals genannt hat, bei der Entlassung von Jens Hertel, waren schon plausibel. Also der FCM hatte dann irgendwie auch eine Serie von Spielen verloren, hat eben auch gegen Heidenheim sehr hoch verloren, wo sie eigentlich die bessere Mannschaft waren, über größere Teile des Spiels. Dann haben sie irgendwie zwei, drei Spiele gehabt, wo sie geführt haben, wo sie dann kurz vor Schluss noch nicht nur den Sieg aus der Hand gegeben haben, sondern einfach auch das Spiel noch verloren haben. Und ich glaube, der größte Vorwurf an Jens Hertel war seine Rotation. Also er hat immer sehr stark die Mannschaft irgendwie am Gegner ausgerichtet und da wirklich vier, fünf, sechs Leute pro Spiel rotiert und umgestellt und alles Mögliche versucht. Und ich glaube, das ist ihm am Ende so ein bisschen zum Verhängnis geworden, weil Mario Kalnick dann auch ganz klar gesagt hat, naja, nach der Entlassung stand heute, wir haben keine eingespielte Stammmannschaft, wir haben irgendwie die schlechteste Defensive und so weiter. Und das waren natürlich genau die Punkte, stabile Defensive, eine gewisse eingespielt hat, die den FCM über Jahre stark gemacht hat. Und dann kam Michael Euning und der hat das auch genau geändert. Also der hat dann sehr oft mit wirklich der der gleichen Mannschaft gespielt oder eben nur auf ein oder zwei Positionen verändert. Der FCM ist mutiger aufgetreten, hat offensiver gespielt, hat sich mehr Chancen erarbeitet. Also in der Hinsicht hat es schon funktioniert oder diese Sachen, die Jens Härtel angekreidet wurden, hat Michael Euning schon anders gemacht. Nur das Ergebnis war eben nicht, sagen wir mal nicht, nicht ausreichend, um dann die Lücke, die in dem Moment schon da war, zu schließen.
Ja, gut. Also man findet ja eigentlich meistens dann gute Gründe, wenn man einen Trainer wechseln möchte und nicht jeder. Also eigentlich die Mehrzahl aller Trainerwechsel ist auch nachvollziehbar und letztlich ja auch ein legitimes Mittel, um irgendwie alle möglichen Instrumente, die man so hat, um Impulse zu setzen, die berühmten Impulse, um dann sein sportliches Ziel zu erreichen, irgendwie zu verfolgen. Aber mich hat eben dieser Blick eben einfach auf Jens Härtel nochmal interessiert, weil ich da eben auch nicht nahe genug dran bin. Jetzt hast du gesagt, unter Michael Ending hat sich einiges verändert, aber die offensiven Probleme bleiben. Dann würde ich jetzt vermuten, dass das kein Problem der Spielanlage ist, sondern der Qualität vorne drin.
Das muss man ganz klar so formulieren, ja. Also die Chancen sind da und es sind relativ viele Spiele gewesen, wo der FCM auch dominiert hat oder ein klares Chancen-Plus hatte und die er trotzdem nicht gewonnen hat.
Also Christian Beck ist mit zehn Toren der erfolgreichste Torschütze. Dahinter dann noch Tirpitz mit sieben und Lowcamper mit fünf, aber insgesamt eben nur 34 davon. Jetzt haben wir schon auf das Restprogramm ein bisschen geblickt, was jetzt noch auf Magdeburg wartet, nämlich in Berlin bei Union und dann zu Hause eben gegen den 1. FC Köln. Was glaubst du, wie groß ist die Chance, dass man den Relegationsplatz irgendwie noch spielen kann?
Ja, die Hoffnung ist irgendwo schon noch da, aber ich glaube, das kann man leider nicht mehr so richtig am FCM festmachen, sondern man muss es an Ingolstadt festmachen. Und die haben jetzt eben, seitdem der neue Trainer da ist, ihren Lauf. Und ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass die jetzt bis zum Saisonende noch mal aufhören werden, aus diesem Lauf rauszukommen. Das wird sich irgendwann auch wieder normalisieren. Aber ich glaube, bis zum Saisonende werden sie es jetzt durchziehen und werden wahrscheinlich noch, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, gegen wen Ingolstadt noch spielt.
Die werden jetzt noch zu Hause gegen Darmstadt spielen und dann auswärts in Heidenheim. Und der Lauf, den du benennst, sind eben vier Siege aus den letzten fünf Spielen.
Genau. Und ein Unentschieden.
Genau.
Das heißt, unter dem Trainer noch nicht verloren. So und ich glaube, Ingolstadt wird halt seine Punkte machen. So und trau dem FCM schon zu, dass er vielleicht noch vier Punkte holt, befürchte aber, dass sie nicht reichen werden. Und so, weil ich glaube, dass Ingolstadt noch ein Spiel gewinnt und dann müsste der FCM halt beide gewinnen.
Man war zu nah dran am Tabellenkeller in dem Moment, in dem da hinten auf einmal Ingolstadt anfing, die Punkte zu sammeln und dann haben auch die oben drüber auf einmal sich abgesetzt. Also Sandhausen, die müssen sich noch vom Relegationsplatz retten, aber direkt absteigen können sie nicht mehr. Fürth ist jetzt zwar irgendwie unten reingerutscht bei 6 Punkten Vorsprung, rein theoretisch noch abfangbar von Ingolstadt, aber nicht unbedingt wahrscheinlich. Dresden hat sich jetzt gerettet, Aue hat sich jetzt gerettet. Das sind ja auch Mannschaften, die gewonnen haben jetzt am Wochenende. Und Magdeburg war einfach zu wenig, hatte ein zu geringes Punkte-Polster vom FC Ingolstadt, der da von hinten heranrauscht. Also der Abstieg ist im Bereich des sehr Wahrscheinlichen. Was glaubst du denn, wird das mit dem Verein machen? Hast du da die Sorge, dass man dann auch direkt weiter durchgereicht wird? Wie etabliert sind die Strukturen und wie steht der 1. FC Magdeburg finanziell da?
Naja, sie werden, so wie alle Absteiger, wenn sie absteigen, sicherlich erst mal ein bisschen brauchen, um sich wieder in der 3. Liga einzusortieren. Das ist ja bei den meisten Zweitligabsteigern so der Fall. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich jetzt große Sorgen machen müssen, dass sie in der 3. Liga gegen den Abstieg spielen werden. Wobei das da auch natürlich sehr eng ist. Also wenn wir diese Saison auf die 3. Liga-Tabelle der 5. Hansa Rostock hat, weiß ich nicht, glaube ich 56 Punkte. Und der erste Nicht-Abstiegsplatz hat 44, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe. Oder auf jeden Fall ist das auch sehr eng. Also das geht auch sehr schnell, dass man da reinrutscht.
Genau. Also es sind 53 Punkte Hansa und 40 Punkte Lotte, die nur aufgrund des besseren Torverhältnisses aktuell nicht absteigen würden.
Okay, genau. Aber 13 Punkte Differenz zwischen dem 5. und dem 16. Und die 3. Liga ist eine Liga, die der FCM natürlich sehr gut kennt. In der ist er groß geworden, in der konnte er sich behaupten, die meisten Spieler haben auch Verträge für die 3. Liga. Also da wird jetzt nicht alles auseinanderfallen. Insofern denke ich, werden sie da schon eine ordentliche Rolle spielen, ob sie dann gleich wieder um den Aufstieg mitspielen werden, das kann ich jetzt noch nicht sagen. Das hängt natürlich auch davon ab, wer geht noch mit runter, wer kommt vielleicht hoch, wer kriegt vielleicht keine Lizenz. Das sind ja immer so Sachen, die man insbesondere in der 3. Liga erstmal abwarten muss. Ich denke schon, dass sie eine ordentliche Rolle spielen können. Aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, sie steigen auf jeden Fall sofort wieder auf. Aber finanziell sind sie auch in der 3. Liga stabil. Der Zuschauerfaktor ist dann in der 3. Liga ein sehr großer, auch ein finanzieller. Wodurch sie sich schon auch einen großen Vorteil gegenüber den anderen Drittligisten erarbeiten. Wenn sie einfach drei- viermal so viele Zuschauer haben wie alle anderen, macht sich das natürlich auch finanziell bemerkbar.
Okay, also wir müssen nicht die allergrößte Sorge um den 1. FC Magdeburg haben, auch im Fall eines Abstiegs. Dann lass jetzt noch, wir haben das jetzt schon mehrfach getan, aber lass noch mal kurz zwei, drei Worte zum FC Ingolstadt verlieren, weil das ist ja eigentlich unglaublich. Die wechseln schon wieder den Trainer hin zu Thomas Oral und plötzlich funktioniert das aber. Das ist, als hätte man, also als hätten wir jetzt, wir nehmen gerade mit ganz leichten technischen Problemen auf, von denen ihr hoffentlich noch überhaupt nichts gehört habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Sagen wir es so, wenn diese Folge online ging, dann hat alles geklappt. Aber das, was der FC Ingolstadt gemacht hat, ist ein bisschen das, was wir gemacht haben, Oliver. Wir starten einfach mehrfach neu und hoffen, dass das, was wir gerade schon zweimal gemacht haben, beim dritten Mal auf einmal funktioniert. Nun, wir hatten dieses Glück nicht und Ingolstadt hat aber dieses Glück und macht eben dann diese unglaubliche Serie mit den vier Siegen, dem einen unentschieden und hüpft jetzt dann von da unten raus, spielt jetzt eben gegen Darnstadt und Heidenheim. Wie ist das möglich?
Das ist insofern möglich, dass Ingolstadt, auch wenn die sicherlich nach den ganzen VW-Geschichten ein bisschen abspecken mussten, immer noch einen Etat und finanzielle Möglichkeiten hat, die alle anderen, von denen, die da unten stehen, weit übersteigen und dass die dementsprechend eigentlich auch eine Mannschaft haben, die da überhaupt nicht hingehört. So und keine Ahnung. Ich würde vermuten, das war tatsächlich die ganze Saison so ein Kopfproblem. Du bist irgendwie schlecht gestartet, hast dann den Trainer gewechselt und dann hinkst du irgendwie da unten drin und irgendwie bist du nicht da rausgekommen. Ich habe jetzt nicht so einen Überblick, wie es mit Verletzten oder so bei denen aussah, ob da irgendwie vielleicht ein, zwei wichtige Leute jetzt zum Schluss noch wiedergekommen sind. So und dann holst du einen Trainer zurück, der irgendwie dort schon mal relativ erfolgreich war, so der das Umfeld kennt, der sich nicht lange eingewöhnen muss, so und der irgendwo wahrscheinlich weiß, worauf es in dem Moment ankommt. So und ja und dann zeigt die Mannschaft jetzt vielleicht einfach das, was eigentlich so von der Papierform her die ganze Zeit in ihr steckte, was sie nur nicht abrufen konnte.
Ja und sicherlich war dann dann das erste Spiel auch einfach ein Schlüsselerlebnis. Dieses 4 zu 2 in Duisburg, das war das erste Spiel nach dem Trainerwechsel gegen einen direkten Konkurrenten und den Abstieg damals der FCI noch oft aber im Platz 17, Duisburg auf 18, das direkt mit 4 zu 2 gewonnen. Dann kommst du eben manchmal auch in diesen berühmten Lauf, den dann eben manche Mannschaften einfach entwickeln. Ja die finanziellen Mittel bei Ingolstadt, das ist natürlich ein wichtiges Thema und auch eines, auf das nicht jetzt jeder ohne Neid blicken kann. Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, in den letzten Jahren haben sie vor allem sich auch ihren wirtschaftlichen Vorteil durch sehr gute Transferbilanzen geholt. Also zur Saison 17, 18, 4, 9 Millionen investiert. Wie immer hole ich mir da die Zahlen von transfermarkt.de und aber 14, 8 Millionen eingenommen, weil man eben auch Spieler wie Sutner, Pascal Groß, Marcel Tissaron noch für eine Leihgebühr, Matthew Lecky und Elias Kacunga verkauft hat in der Saison danach. 7 Millionen investiert, aber wieder 17 Millionen eingenommen. Da waren es dann eben Tissaron mit der Ablöse, Harder Johnay nach Huddersfield, Nuland nach Esten Villa. Also es stimmt natürlich, dass Ingolstadt andere finanzielle Möglichkeiten hat. In den letzten zwei Jahren profitiert der FCI wirtschaftlich davon, dass man Spieler weiterentwickelt hat und die dann für sehr gutes Geld verkaufen konnte.
Aber wenn man jetzt sieht, dass der FCM einen Etat von ca. 15 Millionen insgesamt hat und Ingolstadt 17 Millionen eingenommen hat, alleine durch Transfers, zeigt das natürlich, welche Möglichkeiten sie dann auch wieder haben, das zu reinvestieren. Das werden sie wahrscheinlich auch gemacht haben.
Das stimmt natürlich. Also die Startvoraussetzungen sind grundverschieden und ich möchte jetzt damit auch nicht das Märchen aufmachen vom Ritter, der against all odds das irgendwie schafft, vom armen Ritter des FC Ingolstadt, der es da irgendwie schafft, sich noch unten drin zu halten. Man hat natürlich den Rückhalt von Audi in dem Fall oder bzw. VW und das ist die Basis von allem. Aber nur weil du gesagt hattest, dass das Investment zurückgegangen ist des Sponsors, das stimmt. Aber man konnte das eben auffangen durch diese und auch deswegen ist die wirtschaftliche Situation vom FCI überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen mit Magdeburg und mit Duisburg, die jetzt eben gerade die direkten Konkurrenten sind. Ich wollte das quasi nur so ein bisschen einordnen. Ja und damit wird es wahrscheinlich Ingolstadt irgendwie schaffen, sich in die Relegation zu retten. Gegen wen? Tja, wenn man das wüsste, die 3. Liga. Also die 3. Liga und die Schweizer Liga. Das sind so die Kandidaten, die sich für den nächsten Kurzpass anbieten. Es tut mir aber leid, liebe Leute. Ich schaffe es nicht. Aktuell wäre mit Wien, Wiesbaden auch so ein kleines Wirtschaftswunder. Ich habe es ja vorhin schon eingeordnet aus der 3. Liga auf dem Relegationsplatz. Und dann könnte man gucken, was das für eine Relegation werden würde. Sandhausen und Fürth sind rein theoretisch noch in der Verlosung um den Relegationsplatz mit drin. Aber da sieht es eben so aus, als ob man sich davon lösen könnte. Sandhausen spielt jetzt noch zu Hause gegen Bielefeld und dann in Regensburg und reist jetzt nach Aue und empfängt dann zu Hause den FC St. Pauli. Da muss irgendwie noch ein Pünktchen drunter fallen und dann hat man es in der Saison wieder geschafft. Wie hast du denn die Zweitliga-Saison so insgesamt erlebt? Also dieses Finale, jetzt wo auch der Fokus drauf liegt von vielen Medien, ist ja irre. Ist das auch so ein bisschen stellvertretend für die Saison, wie du sie erlebt hast?
Ja, ich muss ja sagen, ich fand die Saison total spannend und aufregend, weil ich in den letzten Jahren einfach sehr viel in der 3. Liga unterwegs war, dadurch, dass ich eben FCM und HFC-Reporter bin, die beide in der 3. Liga gespielt haben, dass mein Herzensverein auch noch in der 3. Liga spielt. Also da habe ich teilweise, war ich bei manchen Auswärtsspielen dreimal in einer Saison und dadurch habe ich von der 2. Liga so gar nicht mitgekriegt. Es ist jetzt schon so, dass ich sage, Bundesliga, da hat man so ein paar Mannschaften im Blick, aber da verfolge ich jetzt auch nicht alles, weil es einfach auch, wenn ich arbeiten bin und die 3. Liga 14 Uhr spielt, naja, kannste ja vorstellen, dann ist 16 Uhr Schluss und bis ich dann mit der Arbeit fertig bin, ist die Bundesliga lange vorbei. Also da habe ich schon wenig mitgekriegt und auf die 2. Liga habe ich noch viel weniger geguckt und da habe ich mich jetzt schon total drauf gefreut. So und die Erwartungen wurden auch erfüllt, weil eben alles ein bisschen größer ist, ein bisschen besser. Bessere Spieler, andere Spieler, andere Stadien, in denen ich lange nicht war oder in denen ich noch nie war und insofern habe ich das persönlich aus meiner Reporter-Sicht sehr genossen und ja auch das ist eben eine sehr ausgeglichene Liga und das macht es natürlich immer unterhaltsam dann auch für die Zuschauer, glaube ich.
Also wir können uns freuen auf ein spannendes Saisonfinale. Es geht jetzt dann weiter mit allen Spielen parallel am Sonntag, den 12. Mai. Ich danke dir, lieber Oliver, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast. Oliver Leiste von MDR und von 120 Minuten. Man kann dir bei Twitter folgen als atleisteo.bist du da. Oliver, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk. Und danke euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Unterstützt den Rasenfunk, wenn ihr mögt. Rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Ansonsten hören wir uns bald wieder. Macht's gut. Ciao.